[Applause]
monsieur le president Madam President I
can say madam a monsieur le deputy
borrow parfois list wha ivanovitch
discretion oh yeah picante upon
conscious rap is mo tally laka lost his
sergey duloxetine commission can dispose
Kodama under the Sanka I personally
definitively shows national obstinacy
cool on the proportionality definitively
shows doctor mr. actual comes a
predecessor at an episode and breath
mama Donna longest allowed to be
non-definitive laconic as you proceed
they pass on Co the new donk episode we
and below the screams of affair cuckoo
but the captors are equally
yahoodi Calatrava continue under my
veneer fallopian LLL just divorce affair
he said La Casa de vous parlez Samata
satisfaction potatoes Bombay
no deci it Hawaii well a latitude color
Commission rezian vallenato Ananda
Pullum wha a veneer novelist work
destroy a veritable smooth return
samvit Don a villainous you so clearly
attacked Iraq et al felucca
model a ground gas business marketers
appeal accountant no Tasha please tell
so lay calm possible optimist landed is
nosotras on these mantras this European
Saturday Saturday Aviva durable more on
pay important in Jeff that is it
differential about planets we want raphy
reference Assad periods not tasks
require a can you serious a new Velka
test of on Europe the European Gigante
sponsor lieu de vivre should I continue
to pay I can't you know chicken a la
paix gas
how do you know what the yes back
respect on don't mule in European Nestle
is on Paseo de Mar de fondo not Rafa's
on DET en otra vez de vie des OE o
Patriota smell kin epidural is a control
Azad des oh no nationalism is so fair
Kira jet Ikeda test lozad cadet we
kisses de cupa-hr a diesel is no key no
permit depart furniture European prism
la guerre des are don't exist in a don't
obligation to vigilance kiss impose
10000 to the new madama monsieur le
deputy cal a letter tool in european all
rod we undo mil de suite Dijon a
preliminary design or Tony La Paz
lackeys economy - OCR key news even idea
Dino Zoff appeared in fashion - little
green European economy in croissants in
enthalpy the preventing domestic
rawa the particular attack reduce
Managua capriciousness Mikado's doozy
Managua Sibley's que la población de la
belgique
Ramiro tone the person does not F me
Adama the fan noted what have i honored
visualization celeb Iquitos Vipassana
should shift rest away misses the city
as some people the Brittany nervously
small knob
grass metemma another painfully service
this most litigious case after the
prison puter continue up the Lupron care
pronoun he are generally it wasn't an
sent me over damaged this multiplicative
a in some llamas
cut some yeah if we regress a presen a
in for the delivers up the graph problem
socio some proceeded on legrest are you
see a many abeyance on program yesterday
met GOP a jolly tune for the priests
reserved for area the public rec fr Cal
Assad regime continues st ste toward a
founder a voice Ave legrasse sad Anita
so whole honor hop in o-tama semana
santa Lozano yes Lara IOC reaffirm a son
statue presence commercial la quiescence
commercial model Kela not nearly on door
Caleb curve Denise assist a depart RJ no
serenity in European I ordered me these
are Co comics you a back spasm de anza
present on campus on GPB
Manya says a car chapelle de comercio a
souvenir the security element a
almighty did what it is a mature
ornamental yarmulke did WA the
conservators loss convey a danyay oku do
not don't respect over mengapa Comic Con
tea no effect for the linear the unitary
pain could expose a complan sip a on
date I prefer entendre Lavoie tool in
European pull up the near the resistor
conquer Pune City on April no Santa
please we need new European some bikini
on the venue in force
an container a Washington
je parle uno de la Bob certain degree la
la la que je peux general issue
renegotiation a decapitation autumn con
en surprise Oh
any opposed surprise parce que ahora
pardon Salwa lasse Oprah's Nexus pas
alto CA SI pardon Silveira Santos de
buzos la Bob La Juicy nécessaire what a
G come on Salem knob improve a loss
Donovan says diff'ent la copa de clima
Oscar new opener new villain lasse
oppression generation in Planet report
report are visionaries the not a
commercial energy monkey concern his
objective
reduce the emission deseado for the
militant else non-scientific emo exact a
politic ma necessary let's say Irish
decided the testator all rapidly other
great holiday no sale Ozaki kilter an
amp of dance the Zephyr is only note to
oscilloscope got
de l'avenir degeneration
Oh Evvie dama de pavo Liubov work le
défi chromatic erragadda is no commas no
Evo tamo-guna davontea de la vie near
madama monsieur le mont Kinneret
attorney a developer volatile Kagame LED
fees exterior Oh Cal no continued behave
as say x Raghavan Dante relish a nursery
screen second dose afar Parvati in
progeny a preferred Laura export a SAS
table it a cannula affair avec little
dismiss excessive not renew l original
key Palma so Ellis
D'Souza more ever see a reconciliation
eastward European Mozilla west des fr
affair no Devon Devon ear Dean fasten
Arivaca not attitude bosque de la
adición de gas de barcos oxidant oh uh
trauma
don't search arsenal to fasten a not
Vezina media
arigato Oh tada new say kiseop assala
Newsome ocre le potato uno dos Anjos the
perfect version poor font immediate
noona prove apart a Stacey knows facile
imminent disaster you monitor khilafat
eatin disaster uh knows the conflicts
area English contain Arsenal Donna Jo
soo beneficiary the premium model in the
present with Amazon cause for arrest
Donna montage with me lob up the purpose
of a las Arras Kelly's anchor smoke
Ethiopia lizallen steer the some potato
lasers didn't deserve Lamont Dozier to
be a breeze virgin report even II in
Europe get Hawaii on favela pay Dhaka
comércio a devil as humanity as double
name Z dot I are some topics as was
earlier commercial were militaire of it
Jen Empire said unilateralism
irrespective this account it is as well
desert yesterday to come back
see Rob surround em you account suppose
politic taboos own economic a perfume
military destination knows abaout on a
roll exclusive the parable shows current
fashion in university new Devon Devon
Devon Devon Devon Devon Devon Tosh and
actor global yes we are global players
but we have to be global players to
celeries empirical on the pin for
crystal epic de los demócratas Lin
European de la divas sapore Tony portion
wha-la Commission continue at Hawaii
prepared a defense la coopération
permanent structural domain la défense
Debian plenum o operational in precision
[Applause]
in precision important a major asset on
tawa military junta no propane second
said the divinity responsible a
presentable as castle in a given e
protégée knows it by and even as
interior the exterior to tell visible
Osmo climatic soul in europe fact we
need to preserve la sombra don't among
interconnecting so you know before even
a permit with a lady field and numerous
numerous ammonia no some the
pre-commercial nikamoda new vendetta
bleedin own column polemic Adani pool
intelligence artificial full automation
220 fondo novella network alanda
visuality the knows it via new proven
affair
a condition Kuzma uni unit [ __ ] a mini
parameter system agua de coche de
L'Etoile Sagrada Newton program Galileo
color up rest Don across a lesbos
Aconitum oh okay normal permit on orbit
than see satellite don't beneficial Asia
ordered we cut some be on duty that Don
Ahmad who can it among necessary have
initial Galileo we attend future as you
said a bar see no exclusive more
European solar up cadigal Alejo aye iya
iya da 0 politic news upon calor sudor
native European a definitive more Sun de
l'opéra de prendre to see my son desta
hello pull up the develop a secure G
happily well played politic face card
set happiest day as we not go all put on
to the Nationals sugar kudos module
Europe and European Pavan de la student
a national news et amo el complot Spa
seguir population cartagena de la villa
for Monica and Jose da
Ignacio prefer said conviction Cooney
knew some problem Ellison's mem discover
dear sir party the Union mr. ramadhir EJ
control Azad do audacity and continued
over to you editorials they are value
dust lockup mr. German fortress to
Ronaldo Oman in not amo
Lamont kiss-off Europe mr. Raja Mishra
need Lahab dois it a virus the multi
lateral vascular planet apartment a
tooth in Appa Salamo occultism delicacy
launcher the selection of harm open er
you O Muhammad Edith Newman's a
Philistine SEPA this election Oporto
consider la música stomping feet Ateneo
de res ruta de carga spec Leguizamo
Kanazawa pre-owned abilities mo de DC
lazy legs no pain no Devon de montreuil
color mode the difference until you know
in the suit last arrest in European lot
repeated
London man uncut Devon de montreuil
concern asked well sweet enough do
proven cement the grain in Europe prison
yep resident manager downtown than we in
my spy thousand nonsense were verified
as developers needn't rezian vast
Commission
Volkswagen has 15 homers in Russia the
Steven does the internet be done dr.
Doyle Psalm for the winner aircraft
the availa Valen feel fun in an hour
Oliver if eyes develop Olin dusted this
particular portrait a commission rush
from Gazette field
dd-does fallen have an absolute pleasure
[Applause]
5950 vinegar the Goethe villager
commissioned by Gaston gig an
unrealistic thoughts again with the male
to fit than ready prepare found himself
from the aristocrat wounds tunes pivots
Huygens volume unbroken via an oil pages
because that's that's us plastic about
cement yet the alia clearin my syntax
hidden Dustin Wilson dragon egg arcega
would enshrine dragon behind
total repair amides by thousand nineteen
where Denise Claudia than rewriting spam
anemia of cont over page argument inside
you still miss did site young stallion
hurt up the shaft
hemostat and this is an anger board the
subsidiary Ted so substantial Opie Arab
yoga in in India's Omo Valley winter
site live in Seoul Lovato does
Parliament cantatas even zazen
Montefiore invadin does Legionella been
muckin former Luzerne co-funding their
decide tanked evolved provisions a
leaders who are in the incumbent
Manhattan Anglicism entire body
Demetria does that's why thousand
fifteen first portion arrest citation
for the
I lose I'll spank attendant having the
arguments on fresh Warren and in
innovate even digital mini-mart an
effective virtual informational and
banking Union and kappa teamuk iran and
film vinnil markan energy will meet an
achievement oriented climber politic
unfasten democrats Alexander and ahajni
on two very efficient when happens
involved imagine funds for gentleman did
share dimension or hope as NIST fighter
Steve Middle East battle ensued after
the Commission had a lavash leg confirm
that when Parliament option 20% in
Avenue Vic Grassi percent
taken entire visor friggin children back
listen in Allen Institute on defense and
our phone in the Commission and
empowerment
[Applause]
film of brightest a front-flip an exact
these twists our in Punto philandering
was a shot Union to the Everton thrashed
just to overpay jr. on the be food
enriched testability commits to a
northern Oregon for a memories of
arganda been in I often the Internet to
and famine island is damaged as I'm
trying that site Fenster the intestinal
krysta harden and today and come to them
from before the Alpha carbon test
general is happening over patient starts
on well shaft of the cam from terrorists
out and post dividing the emission
terrorist unions fight when consumer
frightened chef organ con terrorism
cannon kinda grants resulting Lanisha
Simon are banished to Iran completion ah
Steven wouldn't trying via word of no
Amazon for effective when crimes we were
frightened Kagan catfish a full game you
can the nozzle and closer mission for
game moves higher in favor value hope 0
to 10
that's how pretty Commission Oregon for
women's the Democrats in processor Kiki
manipulates you under straighten you
know
yeah descriptors massive build pivot
intéressant opposition
human compromise villain sin Alexander's
Imperials fragmenting and kaput
if you have an area for treating a mark
as of the houses soon phones even
commissions for silicates in August
Dalton loses command 7 over patient as
news with James burden angle when the
untangling have an F forked site escaped
xenon supports and vinegar fish linear
in excretion metal me ROM
after containing of Ritalin and and lung
that central mittelmeer hood and that
proved inside 5015 gelatin for me a
section that knowledge it hasn't
mentioned of was a by headings I'm
Dimitri tartan nourished Castilla
fairness switches unfortune
and you see in London fusion Agnes who
asked a bit windy annuity in solidarity
winter Ananda to fund this is only this
solidarity mission Dmitry startin
abandoned a client runs it in hanging
home only been in Clemson
it's been implied the gig and Bennett
consumers and docked though as the
inspiration Vida kept up the software
believe in the Alton there are these
Unleashed except table books with over
patient signs in fairness the
Commission's decommissioned Miller
that's President often happens salvation
for schlager tamagotchi own pocket if
for the earth as president of CBS tune
yet and finally time to lighten on
tsukune allusion to an Oscar for
Democrats have found to AB recognition
by the unconscious tone surface vitae
the otaku Iseman to dimension a box
right
octo clergyman Russian nation house V
Boren film a big investment super
solidarity solidarity ed was from dollar
sign will see moose of organ is yet Viet
trabajan of misery directed VAR ma
efficient power this twist out to Venice
Devon gate and first actin and first
active over patient cutters woven shirts
in the vagrancy light then as in animal
and plant can brand as you bow to the
ninth looks for militant astronomers a
Venetian dabrander zone on all the
applause then from fire door to freedom
in solidarity - and polish and fire
reloading to spend it have you at its
best
julik Tamagotchi on the leg and one for
flexure Stefan has over patient guns and
Christian roots is for housing granson
mission officiant a goofy tree just
subtract via for did sell over page a
grassroots fountain different over
patient household finance yet we hadn't
missed Ramirez five thousand fans of ten
thousand country to fill again today man
for track some out spoil patient as will
again to fo Mickey Staten Balkans death
or patient of kitchen by Deborah abating
from Azul and rake and a Burton the
angklung with a gun can for convention
sushi and hot don't really run for track
for moon Dirac feel hearing angle Esther
become super Floyd empowerment manuals
an affordable I c-can't legal islands
figure in people often call if it's yet
begun
I'll hit leading the Commission's for
Zeitlin of them dish pizzas mr.
president madam a monsieur le deputy
police love near a donk
do not accuse a not continues a killer
freak DC a dreamy second la Frontera
google sent me a debate on in person
circuitry
Sarah Africa no Devon devastated montage
turnover ratio of X Agron in Noble
County no si nationals and division in
the Devon's ret Tom Vizag a settle as no
African European donor cell perspective
that under debt or developer no Intel
approach select offered millions full of
laughs Rick Napa Boozman to [ __ ]
Allah bhisma damn partner yeah equal a
trip in European news upon bhisma who
meant it the support idea on paper once
the d.school
reliable misery africa not a more avec
President Kagame crazy don't you know
African this undergo Tommy record
Paducah l'avenir know as long as more
perspective drafted AC book movie the
Commission proposed of Rod we in
Neuville aliens until last week elope
unanimous put his emphasis no he put his
on for Europe said aliens Calcagno visa
no family declare she's got demeanor
don't work on a freak
oku the samples in London infinitely a
car the permit on the chilly Devon Tower
give a real a freak ivory dear
Department are zero not the Fontana
system exterior you know say he mem
Iliad is on mobile is about police the
cap on Casimir damage this mountain
sector public epic even Affleck
approach a TV reporter oh gosh a mobile
is Iran would we then cut Mia
Yoho neutral homogeneous dismal Dhoni
domain una cerveza small fountain very
tab difference this year Demelza in
European overshoot neutrons and mill it
will know a future Africa grass are not
going program Erasmus
the musically discount is just gonna do
Miliband set certificate rap of day so
thank me the connects on top
quick nap Athos and Porthos 20-person to
commercial a freak say dasa desa a
vector in European militia short
commercial on the new Nissan passive
visa
she's recovering can you develop her
every way the numbers occur comercio on
her lip is a freakin European there's an
a curve the liberation of the continent
a continued and partner economic entre
partner ego mr. president ladies and
gentlemen another issue where I see a
strong need for the Union for leadership
is brexit I will not enter into the
details of the negotiations which are
being masterfully ended by my friend
Michelle Bonnie he works on the basis of
a unanimous position confirmed time and
again by the 27 member states however
allow me to recall three principles
which should guide our work on waxes in
the months to come
first of all we respect of course the
British decision to leave our union no
but period it deeply as you are but we
also asked the British government to
understand that someone who leaves the
union cannot be in the same privileged
position as a member state as a member
state if you leave the Union
you are of course no longer part of our
senior market and certainly not only in
parts
secondly European Commission this
Parliament and all other member states
will always show loyalty and solidarity
with Ireland when it comes to the Irish
pot this is why we want to find a
creative solution that prevents a hard
border in northern I and we will defend
all the elements of the Good Friday
Agreement it is waxing that weeks making
the border more visible in Northern
Ireland it's not the European Union
thirdly after the 29th of March 2019 the
United Kingdom will never be an ordinary
third country for us the United Kingdom
will always be a very close neighbor and
path in political economic and security
terms in the past month when we need
unity in union Whitten was at our side
driven by the same values and principles
of all other Europeans this is why I
welcome Prime Minister's promise and
Mays proposal to develop an ambitious
new partnership for the future after
waxing we agree with the statement made
in checkers that the starting point for
such a partnership should be a
free-trade area between the United
Kingdom and the opinion on the basis of
these principles the Commission's
negotiators mainly my good friend Misha
bonny stand ready to work day and night
to reach the we owe it to our citizens
and our businesses to ensure the United
Kingdom's withdrawal is authorized and
that with stability afterwards it will
not be the Commission that
will stand in the way of this meda me
Monsieur DC desolation are open DC Oh
some a yo-yo
Elinor may tell an abortion humani
beaucoup de travail lest affair a Cebu
inferred Rokenbok you consider para casi
el sol new Partizan la même concepción
de la finally do not renew the popular
name pas laser attitude nearly finally
diffuse in exam des anti-cosmo Claire
Lisa pray led me measure no papa mm do
watch it pea
to Salah consider LaRhonda European
seola would see be disappear new Devon a
TV a lacquered partner until in European
eligible for the reason we economic
mezzo see geopolitical so medieval
Mustafa preserve the negotiate and Akkad
France if so liberal in European a
predominant sin villain in Farrakhan
universal donor agency open Larsen's
desperate a maximum the possibility
effect the program Erasmus he married
the disposal admire and phenomena in
Phaedra
Canada CD on the set of the set envelope
come daughter's envelope silvano name
please
the opportunity an aphasia and all
startups who everyday cannot reverse
conversion reduce on drastic you know
were the pasta fresh air in for the RAF
this in the day Ivana directional signal
some militants cinnamon also no
military's multi prepare event the
Lady consummated the defense new Devon
this is a volatile exactly Ventress
undamaged is not the principal Affleck
ill father
this is a rapid mo only to rule have
determinist thermal tear European in us
you know Connor Papa des idées Ivana's
Alexio concealed election surrett
increase the democracy no normal or
democracy that what is election elite
normal
DC and apportion loser also see a
develop a talent our local Internacional
deliver a preserve event Annette
existence
Ananda P a vada cleanest
accompany so Sahara lo voy a dejar el
espacio de Lobo revenue Nadia Germany
Mondial la de da money abuela dalla sua
sponte lead in money are not proper
money Alejo Minneapolis to permit an
ottoman eunuch to replenish for all
Collison Internacional de saber Morrison
Oh Madonna Mia a necesita profound year
not we know economic Emily there it
comes with the massive the capital heat
Epiphone the numbers proposition the la
comisión Solomon not want adopt a new
devil in approval La Parrilla elite a
Bevan Calabria captive Empress not
secured important energy kiselev at was
familiar panel on the Left America a lot
Cooper
the nose amethyst no Dynegy navien
digital genie elite a burma leading the
company syrup in a shed these are
European on the lab in Opa on Yahoo info
to sell empirical a commission present
era algunas Andrade is initiative
Porcello Volante national de año nuevo
día de venir instrument active
telenovela susan a european episode la
la première shows affair a dimitri not
amazon on a horse on a funny song you
know economic M&A de condado de como se
alpha Santa new economic immunity a
profound a new manga rendezvous Mahadev
provinces la Internacional de novo new
Devil power of a new economic immunity
for Caleb
yo Chris de venir prefer a to zu salawa
ver Sibiu amongst at revel a canoe
reality program or a key concern Don
Faustino to predict it was ill afford
our office capacity a paladin Salva
Katia the poetic edda
independent color hope salad with Alma
mostly los dos coincided well on the
National an F you know properly who ever
to contain a livable as wanted waddleon
orphan pasta and it Ahmad with see it
opposite example
super on sit
[Applause]
see la razón por aquí el Ojo de la
camisa who proposed a new vote to pass a
vote
a llama to take Olivia Donna domain
prissy novellas no exterior
Jerry pet a massage
rapid a massage kuzava expect a date a
l'année passée news on fair the
proposition approval process they don't
certain domain that on toledo men on my
telepathic 800 commodity khalifa the
treaty calculus american sniper 2.0
decision nonsense
Justin : tyranny tadhana VL across
passerelle retreat lisbon permit renewal
agua fella pre-decisional analytic
khalifa closed passerelle Kira but they
don't suppose they are fish musician
kappa cept enmity a relevant life
physicality the day we improve this is a
gallon or another with the Khalifa
now more mister president oh dear KDOT
fastened a discreet a no dezik our
mental depression priests laser-sharp
olymic antigo Vellamo Tov wha incision
say for the president nonsense on par le
pauvre polemic estuvo blessin key permit
a la construcción European Davos Sakuma
yet senapathi mo internal it a
regrettable loss calipers politic
discreet an tell c'est vrai Sato Steve
ray Paula fastened on certain tread
Pascal vermut Rafa a 2d bar Lee media
illusionist lorac dois Gaston + y la
libertad Laplace n'ai pas de bazan
course the tour number journalist from
Antony they attack us
Yaba the democracy sergeant Presley mess
it up Hoodie consulted we're doing first
ones we never try again dim wave teen
fashion general new Devon
Madhavi Monsieur that who they live
after you come for me Lucia she'll come
for me
Napoleon fabless Nam prik palace
activists the no conviction in on paper
the libre de ba key respect the point of
view design a desert la comisión
supports a total acceptance a little did
one new has not percolate a television
ad ba na certain denote a Tamil
logically set to establish Allah will it
hard wha it all
Isetta guard la primera vez president
timmermans effective and Hawaii Nevada
Jamaica mattress even kosovo Solidaire
pas devant le territoire el benefic demo
family personnel ADSL v la la camisa
[Applause]
yahwah so local unit even par uniprot a
devotee lizard ecologist Eastern
European drafted respect it exhibit a
European en camino de agua Lara's / la
regla de dois el respeto decision
registries swamp Ignacio Mezen
obligación mr. president
Madame Monsieur vous couidn't reduce a
dominant revision no parmigiana disco my
Madonna discuss Violetta in European
service a pallid list was repeated mr.
Knievel mother said Commission it Allah
granted to us he said new Santos Lisa
alayzard responsable de la Bob tell Cal
in front us respond sir Lisa Kelly Sutra
the loop kisara listo para transit
little mo le Commission pass rev up test
for colony open the VNC carotid new
defensive RLS pre-creases anymore
hello Bob kid League Robin mr. Mandela
blow up net were posit inspected a
comment at this event
intl al what it an actor constitutive
and fasteners and architect Dumont
Elia inferred Amanda Bob at reveille
mode pesetas farah said the mantras and
inferred Rockefeller antennas experience
Alva don't concede inácio la voix de
l'Europe to attend Talib comprehensive
distant gap pretty great equity Antonio
federica mogherini F Evans Lycoris
diplomatic deal in European con una
larga Mayfair Ava may the trombone JAMA
people don't like Iran's diplomats in
national conference a parallel diplomacy
European atropine and not solidarity
[Applause]
kedaranatha new fashion the program
therefore to approach realist in West
Europe met on the attempt as at
respected television and European not
recount you know is tsukiyomi fan Allah
gave what David referred ray Killeen
European 10 Devon tells me the sad
emotions Asia Turkey in your little town
you Sofia traveler a deputy don't
release from Korea and whole disc Allah
collision the new associate a transform
all is an transiently from it a good
book irregular
[Applause]
ah foudre clear lake snotel on apportion
swattin komomo where democracy oh just
wait
Cal experience yep it's in Canada they
take the list that it even say Donna
democracy European kumoi
such experience sir the very least
epidemic in Keynesian no nationalism
alsa a Keynesian we operate is me
Eclair a gardens are a spree killer
parties medieval UNMC a clay Etta do
demo Co V national Lutheran Lido Ness
excreta REM DS a philosopher Blaise
Pascal refuse even trans oh poor
Temecula Durham nación European do have
mercy
awesome salut em Rob what Emily national
killer Campos Salvage mSATA tree what ma
ma Europe the patriotism I didn't wear
to the nationalism Bonnie it and most of
Aqaba on the amp was not perish
on ammo rest on feeder ask a Muslim from
tonzura robbery lays up a long bloody
Cal rosary a petition for Duke Libyan do
you know the suit the West the last who
is grounded
eres para oppa Elia Kazan a rebel ad is
human killer up yet elegant affair movie
we develop is a continuity we
continually de l'affaire
Maxie
I believe underscored need but there's
always resistance we wouldn't welcome to
proposal with massive applause voting I
assume there will be support Africa of
great interest there heading in the
right direction in line with Parliament
wishes
very late in the day countries and has
to be the main social issue we will be
working responses to ensure that our
institution is closer to our citizens
the European People's Party is Manfred
Weber president Commission president
colleagues Europe is much more robust
than four years ago you became tough
times I think everybody can underline
this but without you sean plott without
your leadership it would have been
impossible to manage the last years if
you coul had the determination and us
sincere heart for europe you defended
the unity of this continent and i want
to thank you for this and also i want to
thank you for the details of your love
affair which you shared with us in your
final remarks Thank You Sean close Janka
[Applause]
but there is still a lot to do and there
is a main message of today's State of
the Union speech we are in a working
session still we have to deliver and
visit today's announcements of
jean-claude Juncker and the Commission
we can sum up that all the proposals the
Commission promised at the beginning of
their mandate are now on the table of
Parliament and Commission and I would
also add these were not only the
proposals of the Commission at the
beginning that were the promises
promises of the EPP candidate
jean-claude Juncker in his election
campaign so to give a clear link between
what you promised in the campaign last
year and what you delivered in under
your leadership in the Commission and
also on the implementing part we have to
be aware that we delivered a lot
you mentioned already some of the
figures which are on the table on
economy stable growth rate all the
countries of the eurozone below 3% we
have created a lot of millions of new
jobs our companies did so Mario Draghi
gave now a clear signal that he will
stop and and finish the low interest
rate policy until the end of this year
so having this in mind it is a big
success story you have to practice it I
can remember jean-claude when we were in
your office after we got the messages
from from London about the outcome of C
referendum and we were disappointed we
were looking for answers and we were a
little bit scared about could other
probably follow will others probably
follow today Europe is united and ready
for a deal but London cannot give us a
clear answer so the EU is united and
London is in trouble
and finally on migration we reduced the
numbers of arrivals especially through
the Mediterranean route about more than
80% through 2015 so when you sum up all
these things some would probably say
this listing up all the success stories
is a boring exercise and probably shown
the lists are not so much interested I
would say it's not the case I would say
it is a precondition BRIC condition for
the most important thing a politician
can have and that is trust
the people we did it together all the
political families worked on this I want
to pick up only one aspect because there
is still a discussion going on how we
rescued the euro and yes my party the
EPP party is proud about what we did it
is about the policy of Enda Kenny of
pascha scaleo of mariano rajoy of
Samaras and of Anastasia Aires in Cyprus
they did the necessary steps and we
rescued Europe and the euro is the
policy we invented and be established
and we created growth and a good
perspective for the future perspective
of the people and I cannot remember let
me say this on party political terms I
cannot remember that Hollande Renzi ties
diploma or even Moscow BT presented any
kind of an alternative proposal to how
we should answer the challenge which was
on the table dear colleagues even even
even mr. bull man even mr. Pohlman in
the chairman government is your
contribution with your party I didn't
saw any alternative proposal to present
other tragedies to overcome the crisis
stable budgets and and an ambitious
reform programme are necessary for a
good economic future that is what EPP
believes in but now let's look to the
future a Europe of people is first of
all a Europe of security that's why we
welcomed the proposal to present 10000
Frontex officers to really contribute to
a strong border control security means
also still a fight against organised
crime and criminals their data exchange
is key for Europe and I also want to
underline that the Schengen area brings
more security and not less security and
that's why we asked the council to two
further steps to include Bulgaria and
Croatia inside of the Schengen area they
have waited for such a long time it's
now time to act
and I asked the Romanian government to
stop the the risks about the fight
against corruption in Romania because
they are harming the decision-making
process towards Bulgarian Croatia in the
same way all three countries must have
the right to join the Eurovision area
immediately I want to underline this
again a second point for a Europe of
people is a Europe of democracy and
that's why I thank you for the
initiatives to make our European
elections safe not Russia nor China not
any external power will decide not
trolls not fake news not Cambridge
analytics will decide the people decide
Europeans will decide about the future
of this continent a third point for a
Europe of people is a Europe of fairness
I am considering what the truck driver
is thinking when he is listening to the
radio and they talk about the
self-driving trucks
I think he's asking himself what will
happen to me in such a world we are
standing in front of a revolution on the
labor market in such a world we have to
create a new fair deal for Europe and
that means and I think we share all in
this house the general ideas fair
taxation - contributions of the digital
business sector to the future of this
fair approach of a new social model and
today's Europe cannot be united cannot
be called united having in mind that
still the living conditions in the
European Union are not equal
that's why I think we have to do more on
common living conditions and living
standards in the European Union and
finally Europe of people is a Europe
which is strong on global level you
showed in the Oval Office that we are
strong economically a child and you have
to become also politically a child and
that's why to change from the unanimous
vote mechanism to the majority vote
system is fully supported by the EPP
let's stand up let's make the century a
European one again crisis times are over
now it's time for a more united Europe
for a more democratic Europe and for a
more ambitious Europe thank
semaj very group Podell alliance a
progressive socialist democratic la
parola nor le Bulman the president of
the commission you started the mandate
by promising that you will be a
politician a political leader of the
college and even those who tend to
criticize you on a daily basis as I do
of course only if it's really necessary
have to admit you are a political leader
of the European Commission Chapel you
are not the pot per all of the national
capitals and you are paying tribute to
the decency of this political role in
Europe by doing so you are making a huge
difference to the predecessor of your
own political family which I appreciate
but this is not the issue at stake today
the issue is not by the you or whether
the college consists of dedicated
Europeans we are convinced of that
otherwise we would have not voted for
you the very question at stake is
whether or not our institution our
policies are already fit already up to
the task on which we have to deliver in
these days yes we are in an era of huge
crisis once Retriever I do not think
that we already have overcome crisis
think of my creation you mentioned it
think on climate change think of
deepening divides between north and
south and east and west no we are in
transformational periods and to put it
in the words of Pope Francis at the
beginning of your mandate he said this
is not an era of change this is a change
of the era and the very question which
we discuss in our political group is why
can't we go more radical
why can't we go for a more clear policy
change to live up to that migration
migration you mentioned it and be fully
hearted support what you were saying
what takes me wonder Manfred
Weber was reminding us on the fact that
you were the PPE candidate for the last
competition why is it that once you are
talking about my creation you only have
the applause of the left side of this
house and all the others are silent I am
wondering why is that and I couldn't
understand because what he says is the
task of today yes we have to open legal
ways for migration it's a scandal we say
it's a scandal what we witnessed again
in this summer in the Mediterranean it's
disgusting to see people drowning even
that the official mission of the
European Union does not have any safe
harbors anymore because of the Italian
government the right-wing Italian
government and this is the mission of
the Commission's president who was the
EPP candidate for the last
decision-making for this mandate so
please take note of that when you are
going to prepare the summit in September
19 and discuss his proposals and come to
urgent action this is what we expect
from the council friends we will only be
able to put it in a broader picture if
we reach out to these societies of the
East yes they need a new compact they
have an interest by own private Slava
jean-claude Juncker by unproduced Lama
they have a dear interest in safe energy
they have an interest in cohesion
long-lasting cohesion and in
reindustrialization of their countries
and they deserve it the workers in the
East countries deserve a decent future
and we have to set up a new compact and
I'm deeply convinced that then it will
be easier to also solve the migration
question let us talk about the south it
is not parable that fifty percent forty
fifty percent of the young people in the
south are without any perspective
we have to set up a new master plan for
themselves why not this could be done by
the Commission in the last amounts of
this mandate why not propose a new
master plan building on the investment
plan of jean-claude Juncker extending
that to the south and giving back future
and hope to the southern countries and
to make them again the marketplaces of
new ideas the bridge builders to the
cultures that are in our neighborhood
that would be a very important task and
we would encourage you to do so but it's
not only these societies and the east
and the south that are falling apart
look at the North look at praxis we back
of course the position totally of the
Commission and we stand united on that
but look at praxis look at the Swedish
elections and you see that ordinary
people that working-class people who
have invested their hope on Europe would
like to see us delivering on top of our
agenda one proposal why does the
Commission not come forward with the
proposal that each and every child in
the Union in the European Union has a
child guarantee deserves free health
care deserves proper education the first
decent housing that could be a proposal
of the next forthcoming months to unite
the European Union for a new future of
the next generation this is what we
propose you are right we need the
defence of our institution we need to
fight against our enemies who would like
to undermine our democracy Cambridge an
electric car all the enemies from the
outside as well as the enemies from the
inside and yes we need to strengthen the
community method for the last months of
your mandate good luck Banco Vash
[Applause]
they're a group they conservatory refer
misty la parola limits mister and a good
constable mister mister president
it was a very interesting speech I
expect it would be more over summing up
speech and I was just wondering what
will we did proportion between pluses
and minuses of course on the plus side I
would put younger plan which you
mentioned our Poisson but I think which
was has been a success but there is also
a minus side I mean the first thing that
comes to mind is is because in
immigration and demographic crisis of
course you did not do it directly
it was Chancellor Merkel who opened the
European borders but but you you could
have prevented her at least try to
prevent her I don't know with what
effect but at least you could have now
we can of course subscribe to the idea
of strengthening European borders but I
think it's a somewhat belated proposal I
mean we could have talked about it some
time ago instead we spent a couple of
years on imposing the solution that was
absurd from the very beginning the
mandatory relocation and there was a lot
of energy span of it a lot of bad blood
was shed and a typical sheriff of
bullying and invectives were thrown
around so but the real question is that
you should ask yourself am we all should
ask ourselves is the European Union
in a better shape now than it was when
you took office and I think the answer
is clear no with all due respect
president Yunker and all the successes
that you had know there has never been a
time in the history of European
integration in where Europe was more
disunited than it is now you talked
about unity no the unity is no longer
there it doesn't mean World War 1 or
World War 2 until recently
integration was one way street now it's
two way streets the number of people who
are dissatisfied deeply dissatisfied
with the European project is increasing
that's why our colleagues my colleagues
- are somewhat nervous before the
elections because they do not know what
will happen they're afraid of possible
political earthquake and you cannot say
that the European Commission has no
share in it and no responsibility there
is at least political responsibility I
mean come on there is some relation
between cause and effect it's not the
fact that there are so many people who
have been antagonized made angry
irritated marginalist bullied rejected
the number is so high that you cannot
neglect it and you cannot decline any
responsibility for that you not as a
person but you as a chief of the
important European institution so I
would say that we have to somehow
rollback this process when you mentioned
that you wanted to
have qualified majority votes in in more
area of policy public life in Europe I
mean you are in for more trouble because
that will petrify this system in which
that some actors are equal and some are
more equal than others
in which the decision making process is
extremely obscure nobody knows who makes
the decision and the division between
north and south east and west it's still
there so if you want to have more
trouble go along this path and this will
be extremely interesting situation after
the election I mean to what extent you
will be responsive to the signals you
are a charming young and I love
listening to you but when you were
talking today I thought my god we are
living in two different worlds I wonder
which one is the true one there a group
within I'll answer them in behalf of the
Alliance represented it's terrifying
what do you say he's saying here that we
were never so disunited as today as he
has forgotten what Europe was between
the two world wars as he says forgotten
what Europe was in the Cold War you have
never heard about the wall and the
Berlin wall and the Iron Curtain Europe
is united now it's not missing a hooker
it's not mr. LaHood Co you have another
vision
you say I'm of another world that
mystery of all very well for me no
problem it doesn't say things that are
completely crazy in a continent that
have seen 20 millions of that and
victims because of nationalism and
populism as you defended today that's
the point
I have to tell you I didn't want to
start trunkload with this but I find it
so terrifying that somebody gave us here
lessons about unity in Europe and then
trying with his government to do against
the rule of law against a number of
other things things that are against
European values sorry but I want to
applaud I'm sorry but I didn't want to
start I wanted to start with applaud the
state of the union of jean-claude
Juncker and especially a part that
nobody has talking about until now in
the interventions and is the part on
Africa short load because you're right I
think you have done a clear proposal
they don't need charity what they need
is a true partnership between us and and
we and I think it's possible to create
what I call the biggest economic and
trade area in the world because if
Europe does that with Africa it will
become the ban is already the biggest
trade area and it will also in my
opinion be a true alternative for Africa
for the African citizens for the African
people to the takeover by the Chinese
what is happening every day every week
in every investment today in Africa so I
think that this Parliament has to
support you in this goal the question
for me is a little bit different than
the question of the other groups leaders
the question is last year you give us
your legacy you repeat it this year and
the question is can we put it into
reality in the coming years this legacy
of you that's the question it is
existential year of Elections with a
number of trusts that they honor
standard the rise of nationalist
populist is every word in Europe we have
a number of authoritarian leaders yeah
thank you to support me like mr.
Kaczynski like mr. Orban who in fact
hijacking or European parties I think
they do a little bit what Trump is doing
in the Republican Party
but let's be honest and your voice is
only an affirmation of this the
inconvenient truth is that all tried in
Europe is trying to undermine this
European Union and is in fact trying to
take over the European politics from
within and to do exactly the opposite
and the agenda that jean-claude Juncker
has presented us today and for that
reason I think and I think that
everybody of us certainly mum fret is
aware of this that in a few moments the
vote we're gonna have it's so important
that all pro Europeans all pro Europeans
are united against this outright utter
Italian tendency that we see in a number
of our countries because leading
European Union because leading European
Union dear friends is not only a
question of mathematical strength it's
also a question of moral authority and
this moral authority is at stake for the
moment in European Union then in the
same spirit mr. Juncker I want to ask
you a specific thing for the Commission
that you mentioned very shortly but I
want to go more in detail I want to
answer the Commission in the coming
months will introduce a package of
proposals specific proposals and
specific measures to protect our
elections against the foreign meddling
that we have already seen in other
continents and in other places in Europe
identifying for example foreign agents
were active on European social media
platforms as well as the extremist
politician with whom they are colluding
in us in the United States there have
been a special counsel appointed as you
all know Robert Mueller to investigate
in the Russian interference in elections
and they have already launched a dozens
of indictments that there be handed down
what I think we need to catch up the
fastest as possible
by also establishing our own special
prosecutor to investigate and to stop
all these and from
also in Europe and certainly before it
is too late in the light of the European
elections we will have next year and my
special request to you if the Commission
could take an initiative to this and to
bring it to the table of the council and
to the table of the European Parliament
and then finally my last point I want to
support you in one thing I think that
the most important point of your
intervention was the point that you have
made about the end of the use of better
the end of unanimity and the use of the
close the pass ahead it's a French word
it was the most important proposal and
my proposal is include be ambitious put
all fields all articles of the treaty
that are possible in your proposal of
the close the passerelle because I'm
pretty sure that on the other side of
the table in the council there will be a
number of them who will not be in
agreement with you and it's all based
the best thing to ask the maximum as
possible in politics start with 100
percent say I want the end of unanimity
inside the European Union because is the
main problem for the moment to decide a
number of things for example the
migration package mr. president as you
have mentioned where the council is not
to decide even when it is with a
qualified majority so my proposal is be
ambitious put the whole package in it
all fields of foreign policy all fit for
me taxation also put everything in it
and we will see what will be the endgame
if we support you
you have said and that will be my
conclusion that this was in fact the
commission of the last chance you
remember that four years ago and I'm
always asking myself what can come after
the commission of the last chance in the
coming years so I think what will come
is something different the commission
that we need in the future their
colleagues will be more than that it
will be a type of a new renewed European
government what we need
with one task that is to realize further
the legacy of Joe Conti ogre and also
the other visions that have been laid
down the latest months for example by
the French president in his Sorbonne
speech that will be the task of this new
commission and that is also the task we
will offer to the electorate as our
group as our movement as a real European
alternative on your legacy towards the
nationalists and the populist inside and
outside of this house thank you very
[Applause]
groups can enhance the flow thank you
president you yourself and many
colleagues have looked at the challenges
that we have globally and I totally
agree with them we have a lot of
challenges we have problems to say the
least in our transatlantic partnership
we have China rising up there's so many
challenges out there but I would argue
that then that most more threatening
than anything that the world can throw
at us or actually the enemies from the
inside and then they are the obvious
ones
the Nationalists that bring hatred
division the racists that spread fear
and hate but there's also some less
obvious it's the decision makers that
actually don't take decisions that want
to keep the status quo who just want to
keep their own privileges and who are
just closing their eyes that's what's at
stake and then there's parties and
governments of which unfortunately we
have more and more who use the European
Union as a scapegoat for all their own
failures and that are cutting away for
democracy at civil liberties bit by bit
and piece by piece but a Europe United a
Europe that knows what it stands for can
face all external problems and can be a
front-runner in the shining example in
the world we can be strong if we don't
make ourselves weak and Europe has
promised to its citizens to bring peace
prosperity and democracy and
those promises are still very relevant
but we need to renew them and we need to
bring them to fulfillment and on peace
we have major achievements to show but
we cannot rest on laurels and Norwegian
medals there are new global challenges
ahead that threaten our future and that
threaten our security and the biggest
one of them is climate change we have
seen it this summer that climate change
is happening it's happening now and it's
happening everywhere from disastrous
harvests to forest fires there's no way
anyone could possibly deny that and the
good news about climate change is that
we know what to do and the bad news
about climate change is that we don't do
it but with Trump leading the u.s. into
space rather than forward we cannot wait
as Europeans for someone else to protect
our planet now we have to do it
ourselves and there's no time to leave
to lose and there the Commission has
been way too timid in the past five
years I have to say it is now that we
need to very quick change to renewables
and phasing out of the climate killer
coal and if climate projection truly is
a priority then it should also be a
priority in the multi annual budget it
should also be a priority in the
agricultural reform in agriculture is
both a victim as well as a culprit in
climate change but farmers can also be
part of the solution and here is where
the Commission should have been more
ambitious with the agricultural reform
the European Union has also always
promised prosperity but we are far away
from the Triple A rating that we should
have I agree on social policies and
theirs their austerity imposed on member
states in the past without regards to
consequences and also without regards to
whether this would actually help
anything that has seriously undermined
the European promise of increasing
living standards but increasing the
quality of life that's not just a minor
thing that you can forget about it's an
essence an essence of policymaking and
we we need to renew this promise and
build a social Europe and one not just
of nice declarations like we've seen
from
borge we need not just nice and tensions
that's all very nice but we need a
social Europe with real facts and real
figures we need common minimum social
standards in Europe all citizens must
get full access to social protection to
housing and traumatic occur care a
framework directive on adequate minimum
income schemes can create such a safety
net as well and tear would be very
interesting to see a proposal by the
Commission so that we can ensure that
safety net for everyone and not just for
lucky few and Europe has promised
democracy rule of law and civil
liberties to all its citizens and that
was a very strong call for all the
countries that wanted to join for all
the people living under dictatorships
were being deprived from freedoms like
the country where I myself was born our
continent has a long and bloody history
of oppressions of tanks rolling against
protesters of people suffering in prison
camps and it's only thanks to those
courageous people who were marching for
freedom who were marching for democracy
who did not give up that today in the
European Union we have that democracy we
have those civil liberties and we have
freedom but those very big successes
they are under threat we need to fight
for them again every single day because
inside Europe today
judges are being dismissed corruption is
being legalized newspapers are closed
universities arrest and civil society
treated as criminals and this is not a
detail this is a threat to all of us and
again today as well
courageous people are standing up
marching for human rights their own
rights and the rights of their neighbors
and they're marching for freedom beaten
Sicily or Romania beaten cabinets or
beat in peer in and they defend
democracy they defend humanity and they
defend Europe and we see as well that if
we stand up together then we will really
have power then we are really strong
together and I think more of now than
ever it is now the task and
responsibility of all of us
to take a stance to take up all of our
responsibilities we have
responsibilities phew as president of
the Commission we all as members of the
European Parliament but all Europeans
from north to south from east to west
because if Europe loses on democracy
then it will lose itself and this is
about more than about one country or
another country this is about the
achievements on this continent that so
many people have even died for this is
about our true self the true self of
Europe and it is time to stake us to
take a stance thank you please we need
to respect the timing mr. young you did
a very intensive speech giving you a
political position with which you have
exercised the Office of Commission
president to express my respect for that
I think it makes it easier for us to
speak about from the point of view of
the various political groups in the
European Union Union should be different
I'd like to start with the evaluation
whether we are in a position where we
can say we've got over the crisis all
the challenges of the future prepared so
that people have the feeling of social
security of solidarity of a community in
the European Union I'm saying do you
know very clearly yesterday when the
Greek Prime Minister was here one
sentence was very
clear very demonstrative he said we're
out of the we've survived when he says
we've survived if that's the result of a
policy which has been shaped by the
Union and the Commission a sort of
crisis management which is on the backs
of the poorest that inequality has
become deeper that we don't have the the
safety the security that we can look to
the future we all have the feeling
something facing us we can say today we
have to deflect it because issues where
we have to say today policies it won't
work like that the start of the
financial crisis in many countries and
people not benefiting from growth the
rights of workers in many countries we
must give a signal that these rights and
the protection of employees get them
back have you strengthened them accept
the promised social triple a becomes a
triple aid for a future military
strength of the European Union it can't
be we're taking money from the European
budget that you used showing strength
showing the strength to the outside and
protecting citizens
it reminds me of the Austrian presidency
they stare saying Europe there protects
very clear it's not about a social
specific refugees and this humanitarian
catastrophe that we've seen that someone
is being continued I'm very thankful
that you said descending into inactivity
the Commission activists and actors they
don't know where the cause is like turn
to they can fight with together if we
don't know who is responsible for what
what responsibility individual
institutions in the left from right-wing
attempts to destroy Europe I wanted the
FTD mr. Farr what a picture you paint a
European Union of peace of prosperity of
contentedness and as you said you're
trying to make it a little more perfect
every day well it's a very good
advertising slogan but tell me what
surprised me since your last State of
the Union speech there's been a seismic
political event in Europe but
one even on a par with brexit Italy a
founding member of the Union the third
biggest economy in the eurozone now has
a combination government between the
five stars of malaga that is polling
over 60% of the vote and is posing a
direct challenge both in terms of the
management of the eurozone and indeed
how the migration crisis is handled you
made no acknowledgement of that at all
no acknowledgement but the populist
revolt that is sweeping through
virtually every single Member State
instead you'll to carry on regardless
and I noted your continued use of the
phrase sovereign Europe what you're
talking about is a deeper centralization
of power a centralization of power in
terms of Europe's foreign policy a
centralization of power as you first
laid out last year in terms of building
a European army more power at the center
for taxation all of this of course
meaning less to be done at the
nation-state level and now another
10,000 European border guards paving the
way for a federal border police in
Europe pulla tell you something if
you've got problems with the Italians
now you ain't seen nothing yet when you
put that proposal to them but it's all
about centralization power power power
but here's the funny thing you appealed
to our sense of European patriotism so
why is it the patriotism of the
nation-state level is considered to be
insolent bad nasty xenophobic probably
racist into the bargain
and yet and yet patriotism at a European
level is a good and a virtuous thing and
I'm afraid this idea of European
patriotism this idea of putting that
flag above their own nation state flag
is for the birds
people do not have a profound sense of
European identity they have a sense of
national identity and and in a way that
is the great dividing line between your
vision of Europe and that increasingly
that has been said by the electors we
wish to live in nation-states now
brexit mr. Janka on the irish border
already there were huge differences
between the North and the South
differences of politics of tax of
currency and of law
and we managed and if we can get to a
free trade deal
well of course there'll be no
difficulties whatsoever and I thought
you had some very positive things to say
you said our vote to leave was a vote to
leave the single market and its
associated parts I agree with you quite
why mrs. Mae at Chequers wants to opt
back into much of it I don't know but
you said twice that we need to come to a
free trade deal
it's what European exporters won and it
is absolutely and it's what we want
surely now the time is right the ground
is prepared for a Canada plus style
trade deal between you and between us we
leave political union but we carry on
doing business on a tariff-free basis we
wants it increasingly I think that you
want it let's get brexit sorted and mr.
bobster you'll be happy you'll see the
back of us a condensed form of
everything your commissions when you
decide to appoint mr. Zumaya
as the commission rules it's democracy
said that the financial market would
teach the proper way and it's also just
now you stated
examples of migration
saying for people to organize this
continent and suffering of our peoples
and the us-european with the same with
which it depends
a productive initiative like nordstrom -
thank you
presenter commission la in the
commission during the course of your
speak of the role of journalists as
people who uphold the murders of girls
here murdered in Multan kucik may have
still not been found until such time as
we establish we will continue to speak
out against the course of events
president Juncker has the flow multicast
rocket chemo today was a jicama Sarab
Monsieur bull man he not see the
necessity cavae the develop a divan
towers lead bodies on phone a it was
fulfilled in personally see que la
comisión my papa's a donor card with the
processors the integrated work exactly
mo in the abattoir
Oh Luc Madame Kali
Ripley the author we come here poor dick
let us not the great book nearest Pan Am
make broken news on trapeze but maple to
me transform you know they don't want
you know are not equally active dear
hermana me the Ofsted minimum the
politest
the Commissioner also we add alternate
text Allah protects you know the zealot
of the corridor the body politic
Caturday they prevent attacks you know
ever been don't to Silla it on panache
kill for equity Aunt Polly Jenny Jenny
permission upon
patriotism nationalism
Montpetit parties began together they
didn't have the person gem wampum agenda
that has perizaad as he would it can
even do more difference a partnership
avascular d may another place at all oui
oui je ne veux pas vivre don't Samad
fail
Roger don't seem unfair the end
genoveffa v photon Simone affair Lumia
Kyoto sea-level service regret see the
parole anomie they concede Thank You
counsel mr. president president tianni
honourable members ladies and gentlemen
on behalf of the council let me first of
all thank president Juncker for his
address and for his analyzes regarding
the challenges but also the
opportunities facing our union at this
crucial juncture as we approach the end
of the legislature I won't be able to go
into all the detailed elements of
president Juncker speech and his
considerations deserve a careful
examination obviously he touched upon
issues that are at the center of our
attention but let me turn to something
else at the outset I would like to
that a fully secant what president young
has stated at the beginning of his
speech our union is a union of peace it
is a union of prosperity and we should
show respect towards this union
deal with it carefully and protect our
common values now let me turn to some
issues touched for instance the idea of
further strengthening Frontex it is an
important element of a functioning EU
policy on migration it was already
discussed at the European Council in
June and it will be a main topic for the
discussions at the informal heads of
state or government summit in Salzburg
and yes the strengthening of frontex is
in our view a precondition to establish
eros Island and well based Asylum
European Asylum system we hope to find
as much as possible a common ground and
to bring things forward the European
Council in June also reconfirmed the
necessity of bringing our cooperation
with Africa to a new level
a wizard will expression of the same
will be a high-level forum which we are
currently planning to hold in Vienna at
the beginning of December and as far as
the proposal on summer time is concerned
we are planning to put it on very
quickly on the agenda of the council
given the specific political context
before the end of the current
legislative term there is indeed a need
to concentrate on the delivery of
pending proposals and on the effective
implementation of legislation be assured
that your strin presidencies energy and
determination is fully focused on this
in recent months there have been
developments which may on surface seem
contradictory there is much talk about
Europe's accept assessment concerns in
this respect ahead of next year's
election of the European Parliament yet
at the same time we have seen positive
signs on renewed trust and higher levels
of
support for the union for our part as
presidency we are confident that there
is enough unity and determination in
Europe to tackle this challenges ahead
and to transfer them into opportunities
our motto is a Europe that protects and
this is what we try to contribute I
think this motto could also apply to a
series of elements of President Juncker
speech today Europe has emerged strong
in many ways from the crisis we have
faced in recent years but now we need to
act swiftly and determinately on the
economy on migration on security and on
digital Europe especially cybercrime the
increasing number of cyber attacks and
the crucial questions on cybersecurity
must be discussed digitally we will
strive to use the efforts of
digitalization on the one hand at its
best and on the other hand we have to
deal carefully with the possible
negative effect the goal must be a
secure stable single digital market and
the highest trust of his consumers of
this civil service of Europe ladies and
gentlemen addressing you in this
hemicycle in July Chancellor quotes
presented to you the priorities of our
presidency namely security and the fight
against illegal migration securing
prosperity and competitiveness through
digitalization and stability in the
European neighbourhood I will not go
through these principles and priorities
again they focus on achieving tangible
results through demonstrating to
European citizens the use indispensable
added value for its citizens and Member
States and of course this is
particularly important in this period as
we near the end of the legislature as
president you mentioned we have a lot of
work to do in the coming months in terms
of legislation but there are of course
also the informal meetings
of the head of state or government in
Salzburg next week and the European
Council meetings in October and in
December in which crucial decisions will
have to be made and beyond our
presidency the European election of
course and informal meeting in Sibiu in
May 2000 and 19 when the implementation
of the leaders agenda will be reviewed
and a strategic agenda for the period
2019 to 2024 will be prepared ladies and
gentlemen finally speaking of delivering
on priority policies I would also note
that today's debate on the State of the
Union is a key moment in a new annual
cycle of programming now the general
phase counts led its meeting on 18
September we'll have an exchange of
views and the basis of the Commission's
letter of intent which was issued only
yesterday we also look forward to
continuing the fruitful dialogue among
the three institutions on priorities
particularly on implementation of the
joint declaration on the EU's
legislative priorities for 2018 and 2019
delivering results can be achieved in a
focused and targeted way through our
joint programming let me reaffirm the